let's go with C 5 my opponent is typing
my way here my opponent says they are
closing the stream okay just
instinctually right it's like c5e six
now slower game let's try this okay well
I'm going to try to get in d5 with tempo
what we could end up have well we could
end up having here is this Bishop end up
getting a shutout of the game tell you
this now push chop-chop Bishop here I
don't want it I don't want to deal with
that pin so there's two reasons behind
it still supporting a clean here and
stopping bishop here night here our
bishop in after an eventual d5 so if i
do d5 takes takes bishop backs up h6 to
stop bishop pinning the night and also
night here because i might be wanting to
follow up with the bishop e6 so I think
d5 is the correct move right here d5 and
we'll the bishop retreat right away or
will there be the giving up of some
central control will this pun no longer
be on a form and controlling f5d five
we're going to see about that
uh
all right maybe I should have been in
pre move mode without and okay I don't
know about the Queen in between move
there it's really not an inconvenience I
just block and what I'm seeing here is
Bishop here this is an annoying pin even
more so now because I could be playing
my night to d4 hitting the Queen and the
bishop and the night in fact this might
be winning Bishop g4 oh there's going to
be a lot of holes here I'm pretty sure
there's going to end up being a lot of
holes on the light side now the
structure is going to be crushed Bishop
here if h3 it's Knight d4 Queen back
Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes bishop
or Bishop takes Knight in the knight
takes Bishop there to be doubled f ponds
BB ponds and isolate a deep pond and
that's a disaster Bishop here if Bishop
g5 same story i still play here Bishop
g4 Bishop here fork I think this is just
right it's the best move so deep the
insertion of this check really question
as white if if you were to consider the
Queenie to move you should say to
yourself is it going to pose like is it
going to be an inconvenience for black
in this case it's not I just developed I
might have done that even if the Queen
didn't give check I to just play to e7 I
probably would have I think castling
would have been best and I was planning
on just h6 first and only then Bishop e7
and then castle in that particular order
I didn't want to allow Bishop g5 stuff
so I I don't know what to suggest for
white because this is this is going to
be brutal now this is this is tough what
I was saying about the structure being
damaged is all that all that stuff is
going to happen though so I believe that
this is best take the night first and
only then take the bishop however what I
I mean I could still see it being
defendable over here against the Kings
side like Bishop takes pawn takes I take
here oh you know what I think my night
stands better than their bishop so I'm
going to take here first and then look
for Queen D 72 h three or even f5 I
think that's more accurate so I'm not
going to take this bishop I'm seeing it
more as just being out of place out of
position Queen here here because if I do
this and then the bishop plays here
Queen f5 and then I'm at least getting
this pawn maybe even could kick that
Bishop away later on so I think this is
correct just making sure this guy isn't
going to go anywhere to bother me there
could be a bishop here but i have b 5
i'm going to do this and there's no way
to really get rid of this night right
here it blocks the Queen's view of f3
Bishop here allows for knight takes
Bishop followed by a fork so he's a
tough guy right here I'm these these are
the two pieces i have in my hand I'm
weighing my knight on d4 and my bishop
on in the bishop on b3 this one is uh
this one is much stronger so let's hang
on to him now I think clean here
we're actually Queen here Queen here
with the night takes as a threat I
should um maybe no I'm going to go here
watch out watching over this square
still could win this pond maybe oh maybe
just queenside castle yeah i'm just
going to Queen side castle i have an
attack against this king queen side
castle bishop here pointing at this
square if rook here yeah i'm gonna do
hang on this seems a little silly but i
don't want that rope to play here 37
seconds this was a poor time management
very very poor time management I didn't
want a castle because of Bishop h6 route
takes pawn I queenside castle and I
think I'll be able to do some damage
soon everything centering around this
night is positioned on d4 poor time in
when I got caught up talking too much
about what I wanted to do and they were
many appealing things so that's kind of
what made me chew up that time
okay now i could get this this was i was
talking about earlier that fork take the
bishop and then follow up with d4 and
i'm just going to take even though it
repairs that structure to watch over
this pond and also g7 castled i have
this square covered just bishop here
also stopping this pawn push and
threatening mate threaten me making one
threat may be an immediate rook here so
that the rooks can't double okay that
was missed time i had less than thirty
they were they were getting close to
time as well all right good game let's
back up and flip this a position looking
at it from your perspective brooke g2 is
pretty much needed right there so yeah I
think this is already a problem for
light right here you have to be real
cautious about the bishop being played
here I know I do it a lot in bullet but
I'm not really one to do it in a slower
game I just kind of do it because i'm
looking for something really quick you
might want to think about getting a year
f4 move in first you know grant Grand
Prix type of position your there's
Knight c3 here maybe maybe looking into
Knight c3 before declaring your light
squared bishops intentions Knight c3
because maybe there's cases where you
want to play to be five this is I'm not
a great big fan of the you know develop
nights before bishops principle but this
is one that you can kind of you know you
can still follow that rule in this case
right here when it comes time to
determine is it the Queen night or the
king bishop you should be moving right
now I'm a bit in favor of just this
night
hang out first have these juice two
squares available keep these options
open so look into Knight c3 here and I
don't know this turns out to backfire
really really really quick pawn push is
premature I'm pretty sure I attack it a
second time you defend it I can hit it a
third time and then there's no other
defense ah so d5 I mean end up getting
d5 in and I don't know that you could
really stop out I able to really stop
that maybe there's a Queenie to move
early or something just to prevent d 5
and me being able to recapture on d I'm
not so sure but I mean once it gets to
this point you're in trouble cleany to
this may already be a move that loses
because eventually I just blocked the
check and you're still having to react
to the bishop the bishop in and this is
too difficult to deal with Knight d4 so
really do a watch out for this expansion
with d5 look into Knight c3 before the
bishops deployment and also maybe even
thoughts of f4 before your night playing
to f3 going in for a grand prix a closed
Sicilian so okay I didn't really have a
whole lot to offer of that one but it
did come to a point early on where that
Queenie to move i think is turns out to
be dead for light they're structurally
it's really really tough